le 78 chaque soir en direct de 18 à 19h
nous faisons le tour de l'actualité
locale et l'actualité en ce 28 mars
c'est le Secours populaire qui demande
au bénévoles tout simplement de se
manifester de rejoindre l'antenne de Guy
encour Pascal Rodier pourquoi ce manque
spécifiquement sur Guy en courours et
est-ce que c'est propre à Guy encours en
fait c'est une demande de renforcement
parce que on a restructuré à la fin de
l'année 2012 les activités de l'antenne
on les a déplacé sur un centre social
qui est sur le pont du rottoir le le le
centre social pasteur et donc
euh il nous faut davantage de bénévoles
pour pouvoir aider notamment à la
préparation des sorties culturelles
parce que en fait c'est un peu une
spécificité de l'antenne on a inscrit on
on y inscrit des familles pour des
sorties culturelles loisir et aussi pour
les activités vacances donc comme on
repart un petit peu de de du début il
nous faut des amis bénévoles qui
puissent par exemple inscrire les
familles dans une base de données qu'on
vient de mettre en place et cetera donc
c'est un petit peu lourd et PU pour que
ce soit
supportable pour les uns et les autres
et que les amis qui se proposent pour
faire du
bénévola bah que ce soit pas une corvée
trop trop lourde au niveau administratif
surtout on cherche un petit peu des
profils de personnes qui peuvent nous
donner de temps en temps un après-midi
pour faciliter le contact voilà parce
que quand on s'engage c'est pas
forcément pour une durée très très long
c'est pas pour être là 24 he sur 24 ça
peut être ponctuel ah oui le bénévola
c'est pas entrer dans les ordres
normalement donc bon c'est variable en
fonction du degré de du degré
d'engagement que souhaitent avoir les
personnes ceux qui souhaitent être Activ
tous les jours il y a largement de quoi
s'occuper non non on refuse pas et puis
en plus pour les personnes qui habitent
sur la ville nouvelle c'est vrai qu'on a
CIN antennes locales donc celle de
guillancour et puis aussi le siège
départemental à trappe donc personnes
qui veulent veul s'engager un petit peu
plus intensément peuvent tout à fait le
faire et puis sur guyancour on a cette
spécificité d'avoir mis en place des
sorties culturelles qui sont préparées
aussi au sein de la médiathèque de Guy
encour et la responsable de l'antenne de
de Guy encour est aussi sur la
médiathèque en fait travaille sur la
médiathèque et on a développé au fil du
temps un concept où toutes nos sorties
culturel on les on les fait se précéder
d'une préparation en médiathèque pour
les enfants souvent mais aussi parfois
pour pour les adultes et donc ça
nécessite aussi un petit peu de
dynamisme et puis un petit peu un petit
peu de disponibilité donc on on a déjà
fait comme ça deux deux deux sorties on
en a deux autres qui sont en préparation
et puis on va rapidement s'acheminer sur
les vacances donc là il y a déjà une
dizaine d'enfants qui sont préinscrits
pour des aides au départ en vacances et
sur la fin du du mois d'août on a la
journée des oubliers à la mer que l'on
fait
traditionnellementù on espère pouvoir
affraitter un quart sur guillancour et
il va falloir encadrer toute cette
joyeuse troupe de 600 ans et donc là on
on recherche des bénévoles sur une
journée sur la fin de sur la fin de des
des congés d'été pour pouvoir offrir une
journée à la mer pour les enfants donc
le travail Mona pas pour les bénévoles
qui veulent s'engager pour encadrer
autour de de ces structures culturelles
combien de de personnes fréquente en
tout cas ce centre à guillencours cette
antenne de guillancour alors on a une
petite vingtaine de familles il y a
aujourd'hui qui s'inscrivent et puis on
a de temps en temps des personnes qui
des personnes nouvelles en fait qu'on
connaissait pas d'avant qui qui se qui
se manifeste on est on a aussi des
familles qui sont inscrites depuis un
petit peu plus longtemps sur un
programme crocogolf d'accès au golf qui
existe depuis 3 ans maintenant on est
sur la la 4e année donc grosso modo on
doit avoir sur la sur la le le le total
on doit avoir une trentaine de
familles bien dans les clous on va dire
vous pouvez répondre à toutes les les
dem
alors en fait sur la partie culturelle
oui euh après pour tout ce qui est les
parties de solidarité pour lesquelles on
connaît peut-être un petit peu plus
classiquement le Secours populaire pour
ce qui est les aides alimentaires
vestimentaires sur Guill en cour on a
convenu dans un premier temps en
discutant un peu aussi avec la la la
municipalité la mairie de de rediriger
les gens vers une association qui
s'appelle Baker pour
l'alimentaire et il y a un vestire
municipal aussi donc on souhaite aussi
s'inscrire dans le paysage sans sans que
les personnes aent des confusions
peut-être entre les différents
dispositifs donc ça fonctionne pas trop
mal comme ça et puis comme je le disais
comme on a un siège départemental tout
près s'il y a besoin de d'une aide plus
dans le dur on va dire du de
l'accompagnement social on peut toujours
rediriger sur les structures proches
donc comme ça ça ça nous ça nous
convient pas mal et et on est en train
aussi de voir pour que les bénévoles qu'
un petit peu plus d'expérience sur les
autres postes enfin sur les autres
antennes locales puissent venir aussi
accompagner les les personnes plus
récentes pour qu'elles puissent
travailler un peu en binôme de concert
pour que tout le monde se se sente un
peu à l'aise quoi voilà vous êtes
rassurant avec les bénévoles qui
voudraient s'engager on peut s'engager
ponctuellement vous ne serez pas laissé
tout seul à tout gérer voilà ce n'est
pas dangereux et ça peut forcément aider
beaucoup de gens qui vous sollicitent
vous avez mentionné l'aide alimentaire
aussi parce qu'on on vous connaît pour
ça euh le président du Réseau européen
antipauvreté participé le 21 mars à
Montpellier au colloque sur le droit à
l'alimentation vous avez sans doute
suivi et il est sans doute aussi lui est
revenu sur le le plan d'aide européen
alimentaire qui est remis en cause et ça
va entraîner de réelles difficultés on a
eu l'occasion de l'évoqué à plus d'une
reprise sur ce plateau et donc le le
président pardon du réseau européen
antiprovoté qui prône un nouveau système
basé sur les circuit court pour
justement contrer ces difficultés
rencontrées sur l'aide alimentaire pour
vous il faut repenser tout le système
d'aide alimentaire est-ce que le Secours
populaire est dans une nouvelle
réflexion sur l'aide alimentaire
d'utiliser des acteurs locaux pour
pouvoir distribuer aussi la nourriture
bah en fait c'est vrai que c'est quand
même un le cœur de métier on va dire
d'une bonne partie des bénévoles et des
responsables du Secours populaire ça
fait quand même quelques temps que
régulièrement on nous dit que le
Programme européen d'aide au démunis il
est un petit peu en balance et c'est
vrai que les les sur les dernières
années
il a été même menacé de disparaître là
il est à peu près sauvegardé mais sur
des modalités qui sont encore un peu
floues sur la mise en place 2014 pu sur
sera pas c'est pas c'est pas forcément
installé pour longtemps non mais alors
ça fait nous quand même déjà de tris ans
que on cherche à multiplier les les
collectes alimentaires notamment et on
est en train de passer de plus en plus
de convention de récupération de
produits dans les petites et moyennes
surfac mais si vous voulez c'est vrai
qu'en ce moment on parle beaucoup
beaucoup de la lutte contre le gâchier
le gaspillage alimentaire on raisonne un
petit peu sur des inconnus parce que ces
circuits courts là n'existent pas donc
tout reste à construire et le problème
que l'on a par exemple c'est que quand
ça peut faire joli sur le papier de
parler de lutte contre le gaspillage
mais après il y a quand même tout un tas
de contraintes qui qui reviennent sur
les distributeurs finaux et les
distributeurs finaux là si ce sont les
associations ça va nécessiter des moyens
et des contraintes sanitaires notamment
puisqu'on peut pas se permettre de
distribuer chos n'importe comment ou
là-dessus c'est quand même très très
flou sur les conditions de qui finance
et qui va qui va pouvoir faire ça donc
nous on est ouvert à toutes les
proposition il y a aussi des des
entreprises qui se manifestent de plus
en plus pour à la source proposer aux
associations un soutien matériel ça
arrive on a eu une entreprise sur Les
Mureaux qui nous a donné plusieurs
palettes de pattes par exemple donc
effectivement ça va nécessiter de
l'inventivité tout les bonnes volonté
sont les bienvenus que ce soit pour le
bénévolat que ce soit pour apporter de
l'aide alimentaire directement si vous
êtes responsable d'une entreprise ou
encore tout simplement pour faire un don
financier oui on peut organiser des
collectes sur son lieu de travail enfin
tout tout en fait nous on appelle ça
réinventer la solidarité c'est-à-dire à
chaque fois que vous faites quelque
chose il peut y avoir un volet
solidarité qui se qui se déploie et pour
ça ben on essessaie d'être réactif quoi
et puis je rappelle hein que
l'information ce soir la raison de votre
présence c'est cet appel au bénévoles
que vous lancez pour cette antenne de
Guill encour qui se réorganise merci
Pascal Rodier nous arrivons à la seconde
partie de cette édition du 78 économie
puisque nous sommes le jeudi cl Cambier
va me rejoindre pour la rédaction